et notre invité ce matin c'est Bertrand
Badi bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous professeur et mérite à Sciences Po
Paris spécialiste des questions
internationales on va bien sûr parler
avec vous des 1 an de guerre en Ukraine
puisque dans une semaine pile bien ça
fera un an que cette guerre a débuté
Vladimir Poutine déclencher l'offensive
avec un retentissement mondial qu'est-ce
qui vous a particulièrement surpris ou
inquiété durant ces 12 derniers mois
alors ce qui peut inquiéter le plus
c'est l'incertitude et pourquoi
l'incertitude parce que et c'est
peut-être le fait majeur de toute cette
histoire et de toute cette chronique
maintenant d'un an c'est le caractère
tout à fait inédit de ce conflit nous
n'avons pas de précédent et l'erreur
dans l'analyse et pire encore dans
l'action c'est de comparer ce qui se
passe depuis le 24 février dernier aux
autres conflits qui ont marqué notre
chronique internationale depuis des
décennies voir des siècles
il y a pas de précédent il est tout à
fait faute parler de nouvelles guerres
froides parce que le contexte n'a
absolument rien à voir il est tout à
fait hasardeuse et dangereux aussi de
parler d'une hypothétique troisième
guerre mondiale il est extrêmement
périlleux même d'employer le terme
guerre sans le préciser et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'avancerai
prudemment l'hypothèse que cette inédit
dont je viens de parler peut recevoir un
nom c'est celui de guerre mondialisée
nous sommes plus dans une guerre
mondiale nous sommes dans une guerre
mondialisée première du nom voilà la
guerre du crâne c'est la première guerre
mondialisée ça veut dire quoi guerre
mondialisé ça veut dire une guerre dont
l'un des principaux effets et cet effet
d'irradiation d'une part sur le monde
entier car au lendemain du déclenchement
de cette guerre en Afrique en Asie en
Amérique partout on s'est posé des
questions avec inquiétude et irradiation
sur les autres secteurs de la vie
humaine c'est-à-dire que la guerre
militaire est comme encerclé par une
guerre économique commerciale par des
logiques d'exclusion exclusion de
l'économie mondiale mais aussi de la
culture des médias du sport regardez le
débat autour des athlètes russes donc
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
nouveau et qu'en plus
nous européens nous vivons d'une manière
particulièrement
grave puisque nous sommes dans cette
situation étrange depuis le 24 février
de kobelligérance non belligérante
c'est-à-dire on est aux côtés des
Ukrainiens mais on ne se bat pas avec
les Ukrainiens ce qui pose une question
extrêmement forte quelle est la ligne
rouge qui
sépare la
non-belligérance de la réelle
belligérance et cette ligne rouge elle
est uniquement dans la tête de Vladimir
Poutine c'est-à-dire nous dépendons
d'une réaction qui pourrait être demain
après-demain la sienne le jour où il
aura décidé que nous avons franchi cette
ligne rouge donc vous voyez on est en
pleine inconnue on est en plein
brouillard
[Musique]